Transcriber: Nagham Idrees
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
هل تخيلتم أنفسكم تفهمون لغة النمل؟
تجلسون على الأرض وتتساءلون:
كيف يفكرون وكيف يتصرفون؟
وأين يذهبون وكيف يفهمون بعضهم البعض؟
أثبتت دراسة ألمانية أن النمل
يصدر أصواتًا بجسده تعبّر
عن لغة بتعاملون بها.
هناك أصوات كثيرة حولنا لا نفهمها.
هل أحدكم فكّر في فهم اللغة
التي يستخدمها الأطفال قبل البدء بالنطق؟
انظروا إنه موضوع مثير للانتباه.
حسنًا، لو قلتُ لكم أنه يمكننا
تفسير صوت الطفل الرضيع وحركات جسده،
ونعرف لماذا يبكي
وما معنى حركة جسده،
قد يكون ذلك مستحيلًا، أصحيح؟
أنا اليوم هنا لأثبت أن ذلك ممكنًا،
أريد اليوم أن أقول لكم
عن تجربة حلوة خضتها منذ الصغر؛
تجربة نقلتني من الخلجان،
القرية الصغيرة الواقعة في أطراف جنين
التي من الممكن لم يسمع بها معظمكم،
إلى بعض المحافل العلمية العالمية
التي زادت ثقتي بنفسي
وتفاعلت مع العالم، وعشت أجواءً رائعة جدًا.
تجربتي كانت مع بكاء الأطفال.
لمّا كنت صغيرة، كنت أسمع
أختيّ التوأم وهما تبكيان.
وأسأل أمي عن سبب هذا البكاء الشديد،
وماذا تريدان بالضبط.
كنت كل يوم أسأل نفسي أنه من الممكن
مساعدة أمي وتعرف سبب بكاء أختيّ.
ومن هنا بدأت أفكر كيف أعمل شيئًا
يساعد أمي وأدخل مسابقة عالمية،
كنتُ يوميًا أفكر قبل ما أنام، وأتخيل نفسي
أني فزتُ وكنت في ساعات أبكي من الفرح.
تحفزت وقررت أن أبدأ مشروعي.
جرّبت عمل أشياء كثيرة،
وجرّبت عمل إنسان آلي يساعد الأم.
وجرّبتُ عمل جهاز بأجواء نوم جميلة.
فكّرت وفكّرت لغاية ما قررت عمل تطبيق،
ووضعتُ خمسين سببًا
لماذا اخترتُ هذا التطبيق.
وأريد أن أقول لكم عن واحد من الأسباب.
وجد باحثون أمريكيون في جامعة ييل،
وكلية الطب في جامعة هارفارد
أن ترك الطفل الرضيع يبكي لفترات طويلة
وعدم الاستجابة له حتى يشعر بالإجهاد
يؤثر سلبًا على الدماغ العصبي
ونفسيته وسلوكه فيما بعد،
ويؤدي إلى تغير أنظمة الناقلات العصبية
مسببة تغيرات هيكلية ووظيفية
في دماغ الطفل الرضيع،
والتي تؤثر عليه سلبًا
حيث تظهر عليه علامات
مشابهه لتلك التي تظهر لدى البالغين
الذين يعانون من الاكتئاب.
يعني باختصار إذا بكى طفلكم،
ولم تعيروه اهتمامًا،
فإن ذلك يؤثر عليه سلبًا،
ونرى عليه الاكتئاب مثلما نراه على الكبار.
وغيرها كثير من الأضرار.
وانطلقتُ في عمل تطبيقي
حتى توصلت  إلى تطبيق
يقوم بتسجيل صوت الطفل الرضيع وتحليله،
وإخبار الأم عن سبب بكاء طفلها،
وأيضًا، يأخذ صورة لحركة جسد الطفل،
يحللها وبخبر الأم معنى حركة جسد طفلها.
ومن خلال تطبيقي، استطعتُ البدء
في تحقيق أول خطوة من حلمي
من خلال مشاركتي في مسابقة
معرض فلسطين للعلوم والتكنولوجيا.
أكملت اجراءات المشاركة وشاركت.
حصدت المركز الرابع على مستوى جنين،
والمركز الثاني على مستوى فلسطين.
وتأهلت للمنافسة الدولية  في مسابقة
Intel ISEF/ إنتل الدولية للعلوم والهندسة،
التي تعد أكبر مسابقة علمية عالمية.
يمكن لطلاب المرحلة الثانوية،
ما قبل الجامعة، أن يشاركوا فيها.
المنافسة في المعرض الدولي للعلوم والهندسة،
اختصارًا ISEF، لم تكن سهلة.
كنتُ أسير على قواعد عالمية
وعلى لغة غير لغتي.
مع ذلك، كان هناك متعة في الموضوع.
كنت أعمل على تحقيق هدف من أهدافي
الذي رسمته في خيالي.
لم أفز في إنتل للعلوم والهندسة.
في تلك الفترة،
أحسـستُ أن كل تعبي  ذهب هباءً
كنتُ أجلس طوال الوقت حتى تذكرتُ جملة
قالها لي أحد الحكام،
قال لي يا ليالي إن لم تفوزي
لا تسترخي وتستسلمي للنوم،
لتطبيقك مستقبل.
عندها أصبحت عندي طاقة رهيبة وعدتُ وأكملت.
وبعد فترة، قرأتُ إعلان عن جائزة
ناصر بن حمد العالمية للإبداع الشبابي.
دخلت على موقع المسابقة،
قرأت المتطلبات وقررت أن أسجل.
عندما كنت أعبأ طلب التسجيل،
توقفت وقلت لا أريد التسجيل،
لا أريد الوصول إلى النهائيات
وما أقوز مثلما حصل في مسابقة إنتل.
جلستُ مع نفسي وقلت،
ليالي، أمامك طريقان:
إما أن تكملي أو تستسلمي.
لكن قررت أن أكمل وعدتُ إلى موقع المسابقة،
عبأتُ طلب التسجيل،
وتخطيت ثلاث مراحل بشأن التحكيم.
وتم اختياري كأحد الفائزين  العالميين
من بين 8000 مشروع
من 127 دولة من مختلف أنحاء العالم.
(تصفيق)
آمنتُ بفكرتي رغم أنها كانت مستحيلة.
قرأت دراسات وأبحاث علماء،
وجمعت معلومات عن بكاء الأطفال.
رأيتُ وقرأت كيف حاول العلماء والمفكرون
أن يفكوا الشيفرة السرية لبكاء الأطفال
منها أجهزة ومنها إنسان آلي وأشياء كثيرة.
لغاية ما قرأت دراسة تتحدث
أنه يمكن للذكاء الاصطنعي
فك شيفرة بكاء الأطفال.
قلت لنفسي، وجدتُ الحل:
تطبيق باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي.
عرفت كيف أريد حل المشكلة،
فبدأت أتعلّم كيف يمكنني عمل تطبيق؛
يكون مفيدًا ويحقق انتشارًا ويكون مصدر دخل.
بدأت أتعلم ذاتيًا من اليوتيوب
حيث تعلمتُ الذكاء الاصطناعي،
الذي هو أنظمة أو أجهزة حواسيب
تكافئ قدرات الذكاء البشري.
وأيضًا موقع Personal Audio Classifier
بمعنى مصنّف الصوت الشخصي،
وهو موقع لتمييز الأصوات حيث نضيف
إلى الموقع مجموعة فئات الأصوات
التي نريد تمييزها حيث نضيف
كل مع فئته المناسبة.
ويصيرُ الموقع قادرًا على تمييز أي صوت
يدخلُ له حسب الفئات المُدرجة في نظامه.
وأيضًا موقع Personal Image Classifier
بمعنى مصنف الصور الشخصية،
وهو موقع يقوم  بنفس موقع مصنف الصوت الشخصي
ولكن لتمييز الصور الشخصية
وربطها بلغة مخترع التطبيقات/ App inventor،
وهd لغة برمجة بسيطة لتصميم تطبيقات
نظام تشغيل الأندرويد المبني على لغة جافا.
بعد ما تابعت الخطوات السابقة،
وبعد فترة ثلاثة شهور،
خرجتُ بتطبيق يعرف سبب بكاء الأطفال
من صوت بكائهم وحركات أجسادهم.
تم تجربة تطبيقي على 30 طفلًا؛
منهم كثير البكاء ومنهم متوسط البكاء
ومنهم قليل البكاء،
و50 صوتًا من الإنترنت لبكاء الأطفال.
و60 صورة لحركات جسد الأطفال من الإنترنت.
وكان هناك دقة ومصداقية
في النتيجة من التطبيق.
سوف أشتغل مع شركات عالمية بخصوص تطبيقي،
وسيتم تعميم التطبيق حتى يكون مرشدًا
لجميع الأمهات في مختلف أنحاء العالم.
أن أتأهل للمنافسة  في مسابقة إنتل
الدولية للعلوم والهندسة،
وأحصد المركز الثاني عالميًا في جائزة
ناصر بن حمد العالمية للإبداع الشبابي
وأنشر تطبيقي الخاص فيّ وأحصل
على براءة اختراع وأكون مخترعة.
كل هذا، كان قبل ثلاث سنوات خيال.
اليوم، أقف أمامكم وكله حقيقة.
(تصفيق)
كنت أقدر أن أكون مثل الشباب والصبايا
ألعب ببجي/ PUBG فقط أو أحضر مسلسلات.
وكنت أقدر أن  أكون رقم دون قيمة
أو صفر على الشمال في المجتمع.
لكن ما كنت أرغب في ذلك،
كنت أرغب أن أكون شخصًا تفتخر فلسطين
فيه يومًا من الأيام.
لدى كلنا هنا مواهب
تختلف من واحد إلى الآخر.
كل ما علينا هو أن نستنهض هذه المواهب
بالجد والاجتهاد والتعب
حتى نتذوق حلاوة النجاح.
لن ينجح أحدكم من أول مرة،
ولن يفوز بأول مسابقة سيشارك فيها.
لكن بإرادتك وعزيمتك ستصل لأي شيء تريده،
مهما كان صعبًا أو مستحيلًا عند بعض الناس.
واّخر شيء أريد أن أتحدث عنه
هو عبارة أفلاطون المشهورة:
“الحاجة أم الاختراع”
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)